this area is now under moscow's control
russian military police made their way
into the north syrian border town of
kabbani
on wednesday u.s troops had withdrawn
from the region earlier
abandoning their kurdish allies and
making way for their nato partner turkey
to lead a military incursion into the
area
a move that faced harsh international
criticism
nato however has been reluctant to
criticize the solo efforts of their ally
in brussels general secretary in
stotenbeck voiced concern
and called for international effort the
war has been
there for years we have seen hundreds of
thousands of people being killed
atrocities so there's urgent need
for progress for for a political
negotiated solution now russia which is
not a member of nato
has become turkey's closest ally in an
attempt to implement a military solution
as part of a deal struck between the
leaders of turkey and russia
they seek to create a buffer zone in the
formerly kurdish-held border region
german tornado fighter jets could be
part of a greater international effort
to stabilize the area
this is according to a recent plan by
german defense minister anegret kamp
karenbawa
she wants to take berlin's commitment
even further
my first luck is the sphere my
suggestion
is that we set up an internationally
controlled security zone
involving turkey and russia
a suggestion that took many by surprise
back home in germany
in brussels the proposal was met with
interest by the nato chief
i welcome that nato allies have
proposals on how to move forward
how to find a political solution and of
course a political solution how to in
one way another involve
all all actors on the ground but this
proposal just might be too little too
late
russia one of the actors on the ground
has made clear already
that it rejects berlin's vision of a
security zone in northern syria
well could the german call for u.n
troops patrolling the so-called safe
zone
be an option let's talk now with mideast
analyst marcus pickle for more on that
good morning markel marcus sorry there
um
turkey and russia are now in command of
events on the ground in
northern syria why would either of them
allow international troops onto
territory that they control
they could allow it i definitely say
could because they would need partners
to patrol an area which
is 480 kilometers long 30 kilometers
wide it's a big area where turks and
russians alone might not have the
possibility to control it all
and one very important thing not to
forget is
syria with its troops wants to go into
this area
an area where the kurds are where the
ypg is they are enemies
of syria and of turkey and to control
this area to bring peace there
you might need more international troops
than only turkey
and russia do you see german troops
heading into this safe zone
it would be a very big step for germany
germany is an iraqis kurdistan with
troops
to help the kurdish authorities there
but to send german troops into syria
will
bring a debate into the german politics
which has not been
seen which would be a major step for
germany to send actually troops into
the middle east okay well the u.s
president has given
his full support to this russian turkish
deployment
let's take a look to what he had to say
this was an outcome created by us the
united states and nobody else
by the moves that we've made we're
achieving a much more peaceful and
stable
area between turkey and syria including
a 20-mile wide
safe zone what do you make of this new
positioning of the u.s and what does it
mean
for washington's presence in the middle
east well first of all
trump claiming to have reached this
agreement is a joke
trump a week ago announced that american
troops are not going to
be in syria any longer so to claim that
the agreement between russia
and turkey is a u.s agreement it's not
worth
the words he has said so the americans
are out of there the russians and the
turks are in that's the new situation on
the ground and this is what trump is
trying to hide
okay the americans are maintaining
somewhat of a troop position
though in syria where are american
troops redeploying to inside syria
they are deploying to the northeast of
syria where a lot of the oil fields are
and they are there to protect the oil
fields from being attacked by the
islamic state again
together with the kurds so you have a
kurdish american
small alliance still on the ground but
the major trend is america
is not only leaving syria but is giving
up the middle east
as the whole region to russia as the new
major power in the region
okay the questions about russia also
touch on
nato as far as nato is concerned we're
looking at a completely new military
realignment turkey engaged in a
sophisticated patrolling operation
with russian troops now russia is of
course nato's arch rival it's why nato
was created in the first place what does
this say about the coherence of the nato
alliance right now
nato is not as stable anymore as it was
before and this
turkish russian alliance which is
forming right now has already
given signs of breaking down of turkey
being a reliable partner inside nato so
this russian
alignment with turkey might defeat
turkey inside nato further this is not a
sign of stability it's a sign of
weakness for nato
okay marcus bickle mid east analyst for
us today thanks very much for that
marcus thank you